focusing on what you can't do awesome
did you have a lot of um like did you
have lady attention during that time was
that something that caused any
distraction because I know it's hard to
do both especially when there's like
lady attention yes so did you have a
lady attention that's a nice way yeah
well you know like girls you know when
you're interested in a girl I've seen
guys just like throw out what they're
doing just because of the girl you know
well like Kanye once said who's all up
in the news these days I don't know
what's better getting later getting paid
I know when I'm focused on one the
other's getting away doesn't sound like
he was focusing on the lady attention at
that time but did you have that money
adaptation like your friends were there
any like how did that go how what like
stopped you what was that your friend
group is very influential and at that
time especially in the restaurant
industry yeah it's get off work at 9 30
10 o'clock go party sleep in until noon
the next day get up do it again that's
like the Bermuda Triangle so many of
them fall into they don't get out of
right yeah if I'm being honest What
stopped me out of it was at that time in
my life I was waiting for marriage I did
I was a virgin and I didn't want so when
you when you have Temptation come your
way when you're not waiting you look at
it like okay is that are they good for
this reason or this reason like you guys
talk about this all the time right when
there's one path and that's the only
path you want it's a very clear decision
like no I'm not doing that because we
don't get along we don't have the same
values she's not wanting to be married
she's kind of getting passed around the
friend group of people we have that is
not appealing and so I just kept going
right and like that level of focus
having Clarity of what you want whether
it's in a relationship whether it's in a
business it it makes such an easy
decision out of the distractions that
can come your way right it's when you
open yourself up to everything that like
80 of your day is trying to figure out
well where do I want to go you only have
20 left to even yeah I mean it sounds
like you abided by the chase success not
women philosophy and I'm sure you've had
some fun in your day don't get me wrong
but when you're
tunnel focused on success yeah there's
going to be some peripheral stuff that
goes on in your life but as you've
realized I'm sure the more successful
you get the more options you're going to
have whether that's business whether
it's relationships whether that's
networking good things will happen the
more successful you become yeah but I
didn't know that at the time
how did you get clarity like that at
such a young age
I think part of it probably had to do
with seeing how much my parents fought
and just knowing like marriage is hard
there's no way around it and I could
kind of sense I don't know where it came
from I would guess my relationship with
God had something to do with that where
I understood like if you want to be a
Navy SEAL it's very hard you have to
prepare to go be a Navy SEAL you don't
accidentally do it playing sports every
off-season you're preparing for the
season that's coming and you're thinking
in your head that other guy wants to
take my starting spot that other player
wants to beat us there's a competition
that I was very well aware of in the
world that men deal with that I don't
think every other young man understood
you're in a competition yeah it looks
like a nice Friendly's World we're
living in it's freaking not that dude
will take your minutes he will take your
spot that girl will like him instead of
you this is a brutal world that you're
that I'm living in and I looked at
marriage like if you're not being
prepared for what it's like to go do it
you're gonna fail at it it's you're
constantly telling your flesh no you're
selfishness no putting another person
above you having to be patient having to
deal with the person that's wired
literally the opposite of how everything
in your brain tells you how to do like
how often do we have the whole men want
to fix things and women just want
empathy thing like dudes in we don't
give each other empathy it doesn't even
occur to me if I'm like man I I suck it
up bro Adam's not gonna be like oh David
that must be so hard yeah we're not
wired that way no he's gonna say well
why did you lose it yeah I did this how
can you avoid that next time it's very
practical because that's how we show
each other love right I don't know a
woman alive that wants that yeah they're
not looking for that right so part of
what I think the problem is with men and
women's relationship today is we are not
trained for how you're supposed to be
good at interacting with the other and I
never had sisters I didn't have
girlfriends I knew I was unprepared so I
think a lot of that Focus came from like
marriage is hard and I want to be ready
I don't want us to ever fight about
money
uh if you're incredibly out of shape or
you're not physically attractive it's
gonna be harder for her to not cheat on
you make it easy for the other person if
you can right if you're not funny if
you're boring it's gonna be hard for
them to want to stay with you there's
going to be competition other people are
going to want to try to sleep with your
girl and on the same time you're going
to be tempted to want to do the same
thing for somebody else so you need to
find a person that you can be faithful
to like they're gonna have to be a
special human being and when I looked
around I just was like man I'm just
trying so much harder at life there's so
much effort going in than everybody else
around me that was why it was easy to
not just get a girlfriend just because
like I wasn't looking at women that were
like I am preparing to be a mom or I'm
preparing to be a wife I know the
world's a hard place and I want to build
myself up so I'm strong enough to be
able to handle that so it wasn't that
tempting yeah yeah so if you like that
clip click right here to watch another
or if you want to watch the entire
saucecast click right here